Peggy's 16
gather your party and prepare to enter
the world of revlon after winning over a
hundred and fifty Game of the Year
awards and nominations divinity original
sin is now coming to ps4 and xbox one
improved expanded and enhanced embarked
upon a fantastic adventure alone or with
a friend divinity original sin is the
first RPG of its kind that can be played
cooperatively on the couch in
split-screen prepare yourself for a
never-before-seen combination of
turn-based combat a deeply reactive
dynamic world and unprecedented player
freedom begin as a young source hunter
tasked with solving a foul murder but
what starts as a routine investigation
soon brings you to the center of a plot
that will rattle the very fabric of time
you were in charge of the characters
you'll play from their looks to their
class to their talents and skills choose
from 12 presets or invent one of your
own perhaps you'll choose a battle mage
with a passion for crafting or a wizard
with upon Sean for picking pockets and
of course you can hire companions and
henchmen to grow your party in size and
scope battle fierce phones using skills
and spells but don't forget use a fully
interactive environment to your
advantage
good night freeze poison and don't
forget your resurrection scrolls the
battles are challenging and will test
your prowess in combat or simply venture
forth and learn about the world of River
lon play separately online or side by
side using split-screen then drop in
drop out cooperative multiplayer discuss
debate cooperate or even compete for
leadership in divinity original sin the
name of the game is freedom go away what
backs out who you want pilfer and
pillage to your heart's content can't
get a door open blast it need an
important document swipe it from its
owner just keep your sword at the ready
in case of any unsavory consequences
experiment explore and reap your rewards
there is more than one way to solve each
quest to leave no stone unturned and no
pet unintel lines of fully voiced
dialogue an expanded storyline with a
brand new extended ending new skills
spells and talents and hours of new
content and much more the deceitfully
vibrant world of River lon has never
been so expansive divinity original sin
Enhanced Edition is coming to xbox one
ps4 PC Mac and steamos this holiday
season so stay tuned source hunters